So, I hope that we were able to understand that how this chatting works and you probably
executed it and you can just type exit to exit from this loop and you can utilize this
in any of the aspect of your work. So, let us now move on to this part of the course
where we will discuss about this fine tuning process and we for that we will need to install
these few things. One is evaluate herring phase, I do not remember if we will need to
install this herring phase library or not, but yeah. So, this is data sets also we are
going to use. So, what is data sets? So, let us go on to this data sets thing. So, data
sets you will see that in herring phase it is another library that gives you direct access
to data sets. Also if you have some local data sets with you, you can load those data
set using this data sets library. So, that does it can be streamlined basically the part
where we are just going to give to the model. So, we are going to train a model we are going
to test some model. So, for that you will see that using this data sets will be handy
because it will convert it to the perfect like pipeline that will be required by the
model. So, you do not have to do any kind of preprocessing and all from your end or
rather you can just give this that this is the location of my data set and you can load
it and of course, the data set library already provides you with some data sets that are
available in their sections. You can directly give the name of the data set and load that
data set directly without you having any data set installed in your system.
So, I am briefing you once more. So, this data set you can use to have your local data
sets load into this models and all for training the model. Again you can use this data sets
and they have their versions where these versions are already provided by Hugging Face maybe
some of the data sets are there maybe not all the data sets, but some famous data sets
are already present here you can directly load this using this data set subject and
use that into your model. So, the data set that we are using here the data set that we
are using in our case is already present in this data set library is already present in
this data set library and we are going to use that to train and test a small model that
is GPT2. So, this GPT2 is free available you do not need a get a repository for that. So,
that is a good thing and we can have a test of idea like how that can be done.
So, in general what we are going to do I am just giving you a good idea about it. So,
this will be tweets and there will be the sentiments. So, these are the tweets and these
are the sentiments and we want to train that model using the data that we have. So, we
will get this training data and we pass this to the LLM essentially we just pass this tweet
to the LLM asking what will be the sentiment of this. So, we pass that and the LLM generate
a sentiment and the actual sentiment related to that particular tweet is used to calculate
the loss. So, this is the loss function that we use and then again you can back propagate
this loss through the model to actually train it. So, this is the general procedure that
we will follow. So, we install this require libraries using this function I can just see.
These are the various libraries again we are going to use. So, from transformers it directly
gives you again access to GPT2 tokenizer we have already seen tokenizer for T5 model here
we are seeing the tokenizer for GPT2 model. Then again this transformers for GPT2 for
sequence classification. So, this is the model actual model from transformers we are taking
two different classes one is the trainer class we already talked about it and the initial
section and this training arguments. Training arguments actually gives you the flexibility
of providing the arguments for training that how much you want to train for what will be
the different parameters for training and all. And this trainer class is responsible
for training the model basically the learning this gradients through this models. And the
other things we have already seen from datasets we are importing this loaded dataset function
it actually gives us access to that dataset that is present either in our local system
or in our hugging page library right. So, this load dataset is there and once we have
this present we will see that we will provide this as an input to the model. So, this is
one important steps at least for this particular task where we are setting the OS environment
when DB underscore disabled and we are making it true because what happens is that it might
require access to when DB some of the time to log the different things that the model
is performing. So, we do not want that we do not want any kind of like warning messages
here also. So, that is why we are just disabling this particular facility we do not want log,
but once we are doing some research work or something like that you probably want this
log to be true. So, this load dataset is very easy function
which is give the name of the dataset. So, the name of the dataset is MTEB slash twit
sentiment extraction. So, this dataset is already provided by hugging face you can directly
load this into this using this load dataset function. And let us see that what is the
dataset that we have. So, in this DF we are actually storing this train part of this dataset.
So, this dataset has this train function this test function. So, there are different sections
of this dataset already provided to you. So, that in the DF we are just storing this train
dataset. So, it will download this dataset and all once we have that we can just see
what is the data that we have. So, I have responded it if I were going. So, these are
the different text in the training set and this is the level level is nothing but the
sentiment of course. And you can get the idea about this dataset
what is this dataset about and all in that particular section in the dataset library.
If you just search with this name of twit sentiment analysis you will see that what dataset we
are using. So, you search the internet and you will see that there are different information
about this dataset. So, here you will see that what is the dataset that we are working
with. And you can go through this research papers also which actually talks about this
dataset and works with this dataset. So, this is the training data that we have. So, now
we want to load the model tokenizer. So, why this is important in the very first stage
here is because we are going to train a model and the tokenizer will be used to tokenize
this input text. We have already discussed this why that is important. So, now this tokenizer
will have this GPT2 tokenizer object that we have used from pretend and we are giving
the name of the model as GPT2. It can access to some other models this is a very small
model. And this tokenizer will just put this pad token as the end of sentence token. So,
in the previous like thing we were seeing that they were warning that pad token is replaced
using end of sentence token. So, to do that we are just replacing it by ourselves manually
and as simple as that we are just replacing this tokenizer values. So, function to tokenize
each example. So, what happens we are going to loop through each of this text one by one
and we are to tokenize this text in the examples. For that we are creating a spatial function
of tokenizer and it takes the examples and it returns each of the tokenized examples.
So, examples text it passes it through this tokenizer object and returns the tokenized
text. So, now the tokenized dataset how we can just confirm we can just use this dataset
dot map function and we can give this tokenized function it actually tokenizes using the tokenizer
and batch equal to true actually ensures that you are using batch execution and this batching
is actually done the batch size and all the other parameters are actually selected automatically
you do not have to do anything. So, if you run that you will see that the tokenizer is
being loaded downloaded. So, it will take some time and once that is done it will just tokenize
your particular dataset.
Now, you see that we have this tokenized dataset and now we are going to test and train split
this dataset. Now, you might be confused because we have already taken the train part of the
data actually we are not going to use a big amount of dataset, but instead we are just
taking the strain section we are splitting this strain sectioning into two parts again
which is the train part and this test part. So, the train part in the second phase is
going to be used for training the model and the test part is used to test the model.
So, it is downloaded and it is executed properly right. So, now what we want is we want to
get from this tokenized datasets a train part and a test part and we want to suffer this
and keep the seed to be 42 and the like requirement of this seeding is of course, because we want
same result during the development time or testing time right we do not want it to be
fluctuating because if you train with different set of training data the result output will
be different. So, we want to keep this fixed, but in a real environment probably you are
not going to use this kind of criteria and we are selecting only 1000 data points for
this training set and 1000 data points from this testing set and we are storing those
into this small train set and small test set we are probably going to use much smaller
set than this also for training the model. So, we have to select a small fragment of
the data. So, again we are like we are just changing this. So, we are just taking let
us say 100 data points for training and 100 data points for testing this will also work,
but not that great.
So, model equals to GPT 2 for sequence classification actually gives you this model that you have
already loaded which is the GPT 2 models and we have provided this number of levels that
the model is going to output because it is kind of classification task you are going
to classify the sentiments. So, as the source tells that if you give this model if you just
create this model I think the model will be downloaded it will take some time. So, let
us move on to this different part ok. So, it is a smaller model it downloaded ok.
So, now we will define the matrix that will be used to evaluate this particular model.
So, for evaluation we are going to load this accuracy matrix and the matrix will be calculated
based on this particular function. So, I am not going into the details of the function
it actually takes the predicted scores and the actual scores and create a function that
actually measures this accuracy right. So, this metric is actually this evaluate that
load function that actually provides you with this accuracy function.
Let us move on to this training parameters. This training parameters are a bit of important
criteria because you are going to use this parameters based on your own system and based
on your own data most of the time. So, this output directory will create this
trained trainer directory that will store this output directory. If you are using a
local system probably you will be having that and you can use that later also. So, part
device train batch size. So, this is the batch size that that we are going to give here we
are giving the device eval batch size. So, for training the batch size can be fixed for
evaluation the different batch size can be fixed. Gradient accumulation steps is given
as four. So, basically after four steps the gradient will be calculated and report to
none is this is used because we are already we have already told that we are omitting
this Vandy belonging which we do not require. So, we are just keeping it as none.
Now, the trainer function as it is provided by this trainer class you will see that it
takes this model which is this GPT 2 model that we have already loaded this arguments
which provides you the training argument that we have created here. The train dataset which
we are providing this small train data sets the 100 data only. So, we are just going through
this 100 data and we are having this small eval data sets also for the evaluation and
the matrix is calculated using this compute matrix function that that is present here.
So, now if we just run this. So, the matrix is calculated let us first evaluate using
this trainer dot evaluate function I have to load this trainer class first. So, we will
just evaluate the trainer class. So, while we are doing it we are just seeing that by
default what is the performance of the model without any training on the data. So, we get
an eval accuracy of 0.34 not very good. So, let us run the trainer. So, it is a very
small dataset. So, you do not expect much of an improvement, but once the training is
done we will see that what is the different kind of output we get right.
So, after this probably what is the expectation here is that once we train this model even
with very small data we will get a small improvement in our training output after the training
is performed. So, this is the expected thing. So, we try to use our own datasets for our
own tasks. So, for example, if we have a translation task for our own purpose or maybe we are having
a particular task where we are going to give customers feedback or something like that
and if we have a specialized data of our own and we can use that to train our model and
we will see that this model without in the training version of this model will perform
better than the zero short version of this base model right.
So, this is the expectation and the expectation in this particular case is that after training
even with this small data we should have a better score in the evaluation. Let us see
eval accuracy is 0.37. So, it is from 3437 of course like it would not improve much,
but if you increase this number to let us say 1000 data it will take some more time
for training the T4 GPS is not that great, but yeah. So, that is the expectation.
So, I think like in today's section you will have understood about how we can prompt the
large language models, how this chat function works, how the prompt can be handled in a
manner where you can just use a particular loop to like provide information as an user
to the model and get the output from the generated output from the model and once you have all
those things done how you can use this training data set that you already have using this
transformers data set library if it is present in the transformers library of or an offline
library you can load that and how you can train a model for your specific task.
So, I think this is done and we can have some questions if you are having.
Does quantization compromise with model functional capability and performance of course yes.
So, once you quantize a model it will have some effect on the quality of the output it
generally reduces to a point that is usable most of the time, but as I told you the 8
bit quantized models or the 4 bits one are basically the 4 bits are unusable in most
of the cases, but for 8 bits you can go like get away with some of the task.
We generally use 16 bit or in a very special case where we have a very less amount of VRAM
available we use this 8 bit quantization that actually works, but 4 bit we try to avoid
that.
Once I request for access for a model how long would it take for MetaLama3 requested
for access and so spending status I see for this yeah.
So, you will see this error because you still do not have access.
So, it depends on the model some of the models you may get in some hours to like for Lama
models it might take a week also it depends on the model for Lama3 I think week you can
expect that max.
To fine tune the model how many such prompts are needed do we need to anticipate all possible
scenarios and use all for all of them how many such prompts are needed.
I think like you are talking about the data that we are using so it is of course depending
on the data you are having right.
So, if you have enough resources if you have enough data probably you will use end up using
all the data that you have.
So, there is no limitation that you will be using only a small amount of the data or small
fragment of the data.
So, it already depends on the like model that you are going to train the data that you are
already having and the resources that you are having basically the GPUs in our case because
the GPUs are very very important for large language model training and all.
Since it will take time for Lama model to get access any other model with quick access
token you can use Mistrol they have like only a single day and there are other models that
you can use like Zephyr that you would not even require this access token.
So, you can directly access those models they have this pipeline available ok.
Thank you I think we can end this session.